chantal hébert michelle sy auger alec
castonguay bonsoir bonsoir on va
commencer que les jeux olympiques
c'était attendu puis le haut santé le
tic tac de l'horloge à table qu'à partir
du moment
washington n'avait le lave annoncé on ne
pouvait pas trop tarder on va entendre
monsieur le truc dont on revient nous
sommes profondément troublés par les
violations de la droits de la personne
du gouvernement de la chine c'est
pourquoi nous annonçons aujourd'hui que
n'ont pas envoyé de représentant
diplomatique aux jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de pékin cet hiver
avec l'histoire des deux michael et tout
le reste et les ouigours chantait parce
que c'était pas une évidence qu'on
devait suivre les américains
c'est ce qu'on passerait plus de temps à
discuter de la nouvelle du jour si on
avait décidé le contraire jusque là on
avait dit en rupture avec les états unis
avec la grande bretagne l'australie la
nouvelle-zélande
le canada sur ce genre de dossier là
pour des questions de taille deux pays
entre autres
il pas en avant de défiler et c'est le
cas encore aujourd'hui des gens
qui avaient pris les devants sur
l'apartheid en afrique du sud ouais mais
la chine s'est pas d'afrique de dans les
relations commerciales du canada avec
les bons chars étaient effectivement
étonnant qu'on soit les premiers à liste
mais en même temps à partir du moment où
washington dit non avec toutes les
démêlés qu'ont eue avec la chine dans
les dernières années ça devenait presque
indécente dont on va y aller alors
c'était presqu'une trident ciel qu'on
allait passer notre tour nous aussi un
grand diplomate hic dans un contexte de
qu'ovide bon est ce que ça donne quelque
chose c'est que ce texte un autre un
autre débat c'est ce que j'avais voulu
demander mais les chinois eux mêmes
disent bas on est bien content personnes
vont venir
ça va faire moins de circulation du
virus puis on vous apprend invité toute
manière à bord qui vont diminuer autant
que possible cet affront là qu'un
message qui est passé quand même et que
même si ça peut pas changer les choses
du jour au lendemain au moins ne pas
accepter sans rien dit ce qui se passe
avec les ouigours et des jeunes est déjà
un pas dans la bonne direction parce que
deux écoles l'analyse là-dessus michel
des gens qui disent bon bain les chinois
d'un fond ils vont dire tant mieux ça
fait notre affaire mais par contre guy
saint-jean qui fait partie de l'autre
école dit attention là le président chi
sel les nerfs parce que j'aurais voulu
faire une grande fête avec les
dignitaires et montrer que tous ces gens
là étaient africains dont qui est pas
content ce soir alors c'est sûr qu'ils
aient pas content après tout pourquoi on
demande des juges et les paie quand on
était pays tata vitesse pour montrer
qu'on est un gros joueur sur la scène
mondiale
conquise autres vont venir quand même
parce que
doivent tenir leurs athlètes vont être
le est tout sauf que à l'école et il a
dans ce contexte la cuvée de sa ville le
boycott américaine actuellement il n'y a
pas un diplomate américain qui a le
droit de l'argile à cause d'accord
mais il faut montrer de quelle que façon
d accord puis y compris avec la question
des deux méthodes
très bien
alors vous allez je suis logique je vais
rester dans le sport
les deux ch et celle des parce que c'est
loin d'être fini à québec ce débat sur
une éventuelle enquête baseball je vous
fait écouter le chef de québec solidaire
qui a posé une question à monsieur
legault et la réponse monsieur
j'aimerais qu'il soit très clair sur le
fait que le plein ce n'est pas un stade
à coût nul donc un investissement du
gouvernement du québec compensée par des
retombées économiques mais qu'il y aura
bel et bien bon on un seul sou d'argent
public investi dans le stade privé de
steven plantes mais j'aimerais que ce
soit clair pour tout le monde le chef de
québec solidaire va devoir trouver
notre sujet pour faire des sparages ses
comptes twitter le chef de québec
solidaire nous dit qu'il veut faire de
la nouvelle politique qui veut faire
sommes moderne
si jamais seule la boîte comme ça
contrairement ce que dit michel de
québec solidaire
si jamais un stade de baseball ça va pas
coûter un sou aux contribuables
québécois
il était une fois il a redit après on
mettra pas un sou dans cette affaire là
michel c on parle du retour éventuel
d'une équipe de baseball professionnel à
montréal d'une demi-équipe oui je ne
t'aime pas partage temp à montréal déjà
ça c'est assez particulier qu'est ce que
vous comprenez monsieur le bourreau
s'est fait du doigt aussi
monsieur fils gaming qui le ministre
responsable du retour des expos des
mines est responsable de sa commande est
responsable de retour des nordiques je
fais des maladies il pas d'être
exactement la même chose mais moi je
compte bret le gouvernement de toute
façon ne savent pour ce dossier le très
bien spacieux que ça marche l'admin
équipes n'ont pu sauver tant que les
expos sont partis il ya une génération
de fans et puis là c'est un sport qui
vieillissent à deux femmes vieillissent
en jeu pas sûr que de toute façon c'est
une proposition qui si elle est
économiquement à moins que bien sûr je
dessinais des édifices autour du stade
mais le terrain de la cpi de montréal il
est très convoitée aussi et beaucoup de
gens
un stade qui servirait à 48 parties 43
parties
qui coûterait 500 millions à l'éclat
évident qu'on va se précipiter pour
donner des fonds publics ouais c'est ça
le principal problème du gouvernement
parce que d'un point de vue personnel
françois legault est un amateur
1 oreille attentive à ce type de projet
là mais il est tellement tout croche ce
projet-là la moitié d'une équipe c'est
loin d'être certain que le baseball
majeur va vouloir que les joueurs
autonomes ont signé ces bons partagé la
saison en trois voies entre un produit
du montréal alors y'a personne qui va
sortir un grand a
attachement à un retour à temps partiel
des expos le sens comme si on avait une
équipe à temps plein avec un projet
autour de ce style qui soit tirait la
fibre quelconque qu'on peut aller
chercher l'or c'est un projet qu'elle a
un peu tout croche c'est beaucoup
d'argent et le gouvernement a
certainement d'autres priorités donc on
va pas se précipiter pour être dit
stephen bronfman souffrant d'un vraiment
très très bon projet le pop le
gouvernement l'avant parce que tu
helmand les conditions là pour reprendre
des termes de base-ball font pas
gagnante oui chantal
même eu très très bon projet la caq a
pas beaucoup de 6 à montréal et je suis
convaincu que si on sentait qu une
grande acceptabilité sociale pour ce
projet là où au moins un petit peu
d'enthousiasmé
françois legault peut-être c'est vrai un
autre discours mais le fait est qu'ils
aient pas ce genre de sentiments l'eau
et
il reprend bab le mans peuvent ce genre
de sentiment là d'ailleurs je suis
brafman se tourner vers québec ils
tournent pas vers ses amis du parti
libéral fédéral à ottawa et avec raison
un époque quand on y avait des grands
donateurs qui finançait les caisses des
partis des gens qui avaient de ce genre
de prouver leur pour avoir un devis
quelconque sur des partis au pouvoir
mais on n'y plus là puis on
s'en plaint pas mais il ya aussi que si
les montréalais avaient élu denis
coderre
possiblement que le gouvernement de
françois legault serait moins pressés de
fermer la porte mais dans ce cas ci le
vote des montréalais aux élections
municipales à l'est pas nécessairement
dans le sens du retour du baseball à
montréal comme priorité voilà puis je
répète pour une chef vous vous êtes un
fan chaîne d'être un fan fini
ses quarante deux parties dont on parle
c'est la moitié d'une saison une moitié
qui est une moitié d'âme parce qu'un
équipes ont l'air non c'est vraiment
bizarre c'est ce qu'ils cherchent
la garde partagée de ses sites c'est une
chose qu'on fait quand on divorce parce
que on est obligé de le faire mais on
fait pour s'opposer qui ne marche pas
comme ça puis d'autre part les jeunes
femmes sont rendus à un réseau social
sont au basketball sur le baseball c'est
ce mode de marchi je poursuis quel
marché pour aider les clubs de balle
c'est un marché pour les condos autour
du
stade mais non quand même pas ok je
m'avance je maman
csld on en parle tous les soirs
l'article i les courriels qui ont été
mis en preuve devant la coronaire hier
on ne refait un tour à québec avec des
demandes des trois partis hier pour une
enquête publique là aujourd'hui le
positions n'allaient pas lâcher le
morceau
on écoute et on revient est ce que le
premier ministre qui était le chef de la
cellule de crise était le seul à ne pas
être au courant qu'on allait à
l'abattoir dans nos 6 h et 7 vies on
sait tous maintenant que des
établissements qui ont manqué
d'équipement donc eu un problème de
distribution mais ce qu'on avait à la
table c'était l'inventaire national et
on n'essayait même si les mantais tapas
0,2 tout faire en notre possible donc ce
président dès qu'on eut de l'information
n'a agi
bon avec je vous repose presque la même
question caire mais les demandes de
l'opposition
ne changeront pas ils vont revenir à la
charge on a connu ça dans un autre
parlement
pour la commission gomery on a connu ça
à québec pour la commission d' enquête
sur les la construction
les dons illégaux partie est-ce qu'on
est dans un film qui ressemble à faire
on est dans un film différent une pour
deux raisons d'abord à l'époque quand
vous parlez du scandale des commandites
ou la corruption collusion dans
l'industrie de la construction c'était
des révélations et des médias d'abord et
avant tout des journalistes qui a
alimenté la controverse qui on n'avait
pas de d'institutions le qui se pencher
sur le dossier ça prenait un endroit le
pour être capable colligées tous appuyé
aller plus loin avec des super note des
obligations faire de témoigner des des
acteurs d'aller chercher des documents
avec plus de moyens ce que les médias
avaient donc des commissions d enquête
publique sont nés actuellement on a eu
une enquête publique on est dans quel
public actuellement qui essaient de la
coronaire gr/km jeté les documents dont
pas ont été déposées en preuve lors de
l'antenne publique il y en a trois
autres enquêtes celle la commissaire à
la santé la vérificatrice générale puis
on a eu c'est du pur de la protectrice
du citoyen lors que le premier problème
c'est que déjà beaucoup de monde qui
enquête là-dessus ça enlève un peu de
poids à la demande des partis
d'opposition et l'autre problème je
pense c'est que pas de figures
importantes extérieure à l'assemblée
nationale qui demandent cette enquête
publique le haut niveau dans code de
gommeries il y avait toutes sortes de
gens qu'ils n'avaient aucun sens dans le
cas de l'industrie de la construction il
y avait des entrepreneurs qui s'est fait
flouer qui avaient pas accès aux
contrats publics sortez le la
protectrice du citoyen dit moi j'ai fait
pas mal le taux il reste plus beaucoup
de pierres à à retourner donc je suis
pas certain que c'est nécessaire vous
avez gr/km qui disait jean-paul le
loisir
demain et non ce y avait des médecins
qui avaient beaucoup d'associations
d'institutions qui le demandait il y
aurait plus de traction pour les partis
d'opposition qui actuellement sont un
peu seuls dans leur coin donc ça limite
leur capacité d fleurance et le
gouvernement donc vous êtes la position
de monsieur le groupe à votre avis
votre certainement pas changer compte
tenu que les demandes viennent que de
l'opposition chantre court terme nos
gouvernants n'ont pas changé parce qu'il
ya quand même un point commun entre la
commission
charbonneau et que ça pas très bien
tourné pour le gouvernement qui a mis
sur pied ces commissions là alors
pourquoi juste et à tous qu'elle est que
du qui est totalement exact regardez
la position de la coalition a mené au
québec dans les intentions de vote le
peu de pression extérieure son poids est
irrésistible et dites vous si vous étiez
un gouvernement est ce que vous voudriez
offrir un spectacle télévisé à la veille
d'une campagne de l'élection du genre
comme richard beaudoux ou dire écoutez
il y en a déjà des enquêtes
bourget la question s'est essayée
répondre oui monsieur martin s'en
souvient de cette décision qui le prive
la commission gamin pendant oui michel
st
c'est il ya le repos de requête parce
qu'effectivement les réseaux chanteuse
de données se le dise a posé pas besoin
d'eux il ya quand même des zones dont il
ya quand même des milliers de morts et
chcd c'est une tragédie nationale
mais font peut-être pas avoir une
commission d enquête traditionnelle où
on cherche des coupables mais entre une
commission d'enquêté qui les gens
peuvent venir témoigner bd voici ce
qu'on a fait voici ce qu'on a fait pas
de croche de que ne savaient pas comment
se préparer et voici ce qu'on peut faire
de mieux la prochaine fois si on fait ça
ça peut c'est un exercice qui va être
utile mais en même temps si on s'attend
à une commission à la galerie où elle ou
à la chambre no c'est clair que le
gouvernement ne touchera pas
ça peut poser qu'il faudrait pour faire
quelque chose parce que les enquêtes qui
sont en cours sont quand même des
enquêtes partiel avec eux pour être vus
très particulier corner ça cherche un
certain nombre de choses ça excuse
certain nombre de choses bien on attend
de lire cette enquête madame kamel
néanmoins avec les courriels que nous
dont nous qui l'a rendue publique que
notre collègue gerber hier on a de voir
ses conclusions un dernier tour de table
sur un sujet important et c'est le
québec une commission qui râlent
regrouper tous les partis à québec qui
recommande d'aller bien d'élargir l'aide
médicale à mourir pour les gens qui
apprennent qu'ils vont souffrir
d'alzheimer mais maladie entre autres
générative et que vous pourrez donc
consentir quand vous avez tout votre
tête avant de vous enfoncer
ça peut faire bouger les choses michelle
tour de table france avec vous cette
fois
les autres où soient l'expression
sidi de consentir m'a demandé il ya
quelqu'un qui va décider que bon je n'ai
plus tôt de pâtes être moi j'ai dit
qu'un jouet offert 12
je veux qu'on me donne à quelqu'un qui
va être obligé de nommer comme moment
d'atteindre décidé ça et là imaginez la
gg deux enfants il y en a un qui dit oui
c'est ça que c'est ce qui m'a kiki kirin
il faut vraiment avoir des détails
chantal
les sondages et leur parle pas car elle
démontre que c'est une demande qui a
l'appui d'une majorité importante de
canadiens surtout dans les tranches plus
vieille le gouvernement fédéral dans la
dernière mouture pas inclus le
consentement anticipé mais a ordonné une
révision c'est sûr que ça va être un
sujet qui va revenir pas seulement
québec mais à moi aussi d'autant plus
que au sénat aux dernières nouvelles il
y aurait une majorité qui disait il faut
aller dans ce sens et donc j'ai pas
l'impression qu'on voyait ses pairs ce
débat là et j'ai pas l'impression que
les gouvernements vont pouvoir
éternellement dire on s'en va pas sur ce
thème à l'est conclusion 35 ans
on n'est plus dans le commun y arriver
quand est ce qu'on va y arriver parce
que c'est clair comme le dit chantal qui
ont une contre un consensus autant des
experts que des parlementaires qui
veulent qu'ils veulent élargir l'aide
médicale à mourir pour ça qu'on les aime
meurent pour ceux qui on laisse elle a
déniché la raison c'est compliqué à
mettre en place donc on va débattre de
comment on y arrive plus que est ce
qu'on devrait y arriver ça je pense que
c'est de plus en plus clair vous avez
été très clair en tout cas merci
beaucoup bonne soirée et à bientôt pour
voir avant pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit